I have to ask you about something I know
you addressed this on social media but
you told your story of being bullied in
high school and then somebody came out
your yearbook photos and kind of accused
you of making it all up what do you want
to say to that person
now having reflected on it a bit and
experiencing all that I am I say to that
I just shame on you I do because um no
one will ever be able to take that pain
away and what I went through no matter
what speculations they want to say about
me um people that are hurt do things to
be accepted that's what I did my whole
life I was trying to be accepted and no
matter whether that was in a beauty
pageant
or a club or a whatever it may be all
you try to do is be accepted by the
people that don't want to accept you so
and that's what I'm still doing today no
one cares about a half-bath Mexican
bitch's opinion you are disgusting and
are jealous I'm like shaking as I'm
reading this because it's it's shocking
it's uncomfortable I know it's
uncomfortable for you to see just
imagine how uncomfortable it is to get
this in your comments and your DMS every
day every week every month this segment
with Rachel tonight was really powerful
and went through just the unacceptable
hate that you guys get what was it like
for you to be up there because we saw
you getting emotional during that and I
know some of those messages they shared
were directed at you yes you know that
was a moment that I will never forget
that's for sure people don't realize
that we are human beings at the end of
the day that their words hurt especially
for someone that's been through this
their whole life and having those wounds
reopened it's hard but like I said at
the end like I just want to be a voice
for those girls that are going through
this I've seen some of the stuff people
have said criticizing your looks it's
all really horrible what message do you
have for those people you know at the
end of the day we all are human and we
all went through this together so I
think that is one thing that we can all
come to a common ground on and
appreciate about each other whether we
agree with each other or not we can all
appreciate each other hearing Rachel
Lindsey speak it was so powerful I think
ABC's doing a great job and be inclusive
and I was really excited and happy
have Rachel Lindsay at 7:00 tonight I'm
so happy to be part of it because for
too long now it was people were getting
away with it and the things that people
say to us we would never say to each
other and that's the crazy thing like
coming after me for racial slurs and
like the death threats is unacceptable
honestly I think that was a discussion
that really need to be to be had and I
think I'm really grateful that bachelor
nation was there to hear it and because
it's hard when you're on the other side
and you're getting all that every single
day and it's just it really does affect
you and when you try to even block out
the negativity and just hear the love
like it's still loud and you still see
it and you still hear it and it hurts